mes chers amis d'abord merci merci à
tous d'être là une journée de travail
hier on est dimanche matin vous êtes
plus de 2000 à être venus on a les amis
de l'outremè qui sont venus en plus en
payant eux-mêmes leur billets et leur
présence vous donnerz une très belle
image de notre famille politique et je
suis fier de
vous en plus Nicolas nous a mis dans
cette position studieuse tous derrière
nos petites TBL de travail j'espère que
vous notez activement tous les propos et
tous les discours qui s'enchaînent les
uns après les autres je veux voir
partout des stylos et des feuilles
hein alors je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec Christian Jacob mais alors
pas du tout vous trouvez pas que depuis
quelques jours tout va mieux dans notre
pays par miracle tous les problèmes se
sont résolus François Hollande a
absolument compris ce qui étaaient nos
aspiration profonde en fait on
nattendait pas la pause fiscale non on
nattendait pas l'inversion de la courbe
du chômage non on n'aspirait pas à la
restauration de l'autorité non ce que
les Français réclamaient accord et à cri
c'était un remanement ministériel ouf
nous avons été entendus merci Monsieur
Holland et quel remanement Fabius part
mais garde un petit bureau k d'Orsay
Jean-Marc HUD lui revient nous pensions
être débarrassés des écologistes on en
récupère trois pour le prix de zéro don
qui je vous invite à relire ses tweet
mais par magie maintenant elle trouve
que tout ce que fait Hollande est
absolument miraculeux et Christian l'a
très bien souligné Christian l'a
parfaitement
souligné on a en plus des intitulés qui
disent tellement de ce qu'est leur
vision de la société l'égalité réelle
l'habitat durable c'est beau la
politique à gauche c'est tellement
poétique ça nous fait tellement rêv
mais si je peux me permettre une petite
suggestion encore monsieur Hollande si
vous avez encore envie de changer
quelque chose dans votre gouvernement
n'hésitez pas à enlever nagette Valot
belcassem parce qu'on s'en passera très
bien mais mes
amis mes
amis de qui se
moque-t-on est-ce que François Hollande
pense encore duper les Français avec de
telles pratiques dignes des périodes les
plus médiocres de la 3e république le
seul que nous avons envie de voir partir
c'est vous Monsieur Hollande parce que
non décidément non vous n'êtes pas digne
du costume du président de la
République alors Christian ça ne les
empêche quand même pas de travailler et
sur des réformes décisives la réforme de
l'orthographe le pays est sauvé parce
que maintenant onion ne s'écrira plus
avec un
i ça nous fait sourire mais ça dit
tellement de choses de ce qu' la vision
de la politique à gauche on ne restaure
pas l'autorité des professeurs mais on
supprime les accents circonflexes on
n'arrive plus à enseigner l'orthographe
et bien Cassel ne tienne on supprime
l'orthographe le nivellement par le bas
la disparition de l'effort et du Mérite
voilà bien les socialistes nous nous
croyons au travail nous nous croyons au
bourses au mérite nous nous croyons à
l'effort nous sommes la droite et nous
en sommes
fiers
mais
souvenez-vous souvenez-vous pourtant
nous revenons de loin nous sommes là
nous sommes bien là et nous sommes bien
vivants mais il y a à peine 15 mois
Nicolas dans quel état étions-nous nous
n'avons pas oublié ce que nous avons
traversé nous avions un parti qui était
ruiné nous avions un parti qui était
fractionné nous nous avions un parti qui
ne parlait plus au français nous avions
un parti qui avait perdu les élections
européennes il est tellement facile de
te critiquer je n'oublie pas Nicolas le
chemin que tu as fait faire en un an à
notre famille politique nous avons
redressé la tête nous sommes ensemble
aujourd'hui merci à toi de cela
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas les
les primaires sont positives pour notre
famille
politique mais les primaires et je vais
le dire très clairement c'est la
compétition et ça c'est normal mais ça
ne peut pas être la guerre les primaires
c'est le débat d'idée mais ça ne peut
pas être l'affrontement fratricide entre
les égau les
primaires ça ne peut pas être des
successions de petites phrases d'an
croche et de coup de
parce que les divisions ça suffit parce
que vous en avez assez que nous soyons
la droite la plus bête du monde parce
que nous vous devons l'unité et parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'ennemi à l'intérieur
de notre famille
politique et tout le monde doit prendre
l'engagement d'être totalement uni
derrière celui qui gagnera les primaires
quel qu'il soit parce que nous voulons
une seule chose c'est gagner
201 gagne
oui gagn et nous avons gagné les
régions notre victoire en
verneuronalp je la dois à des amis qui
sont ici à toi bris au parlementaires
aux conseillers nationaux aux militants
qui nous ont aidé et je suis fier que
nous ayons gagné sur nos valeurs sans
jamais nous excuser d'être de droite
sans jamais trahir nos convictions nous
vous devons cela et nous vous en
remercions parce que gagner c'est bien
mais maintenant il faut faire il faut
montrer que la droite ce n'est pas la
gauche ça suffit d'avoir le sentiment
que quels que soi les votes c'est la
même politique à l'arrivée et que rien
ne change qu'au fond ils sont tous les
mêmes à peine élu j'ai reçu un coup de
fil très aimable qui était un coup de
fil de Manuel Vals pour me féliciter de
mon élection il en était très
heureux pour un peu je l'aurais presque
cru il venait me proposer très gentiment
de participer à un grand plan d'unité
nationale inventé par François Hollande
consistant à faire disparaître quelques
500000 demandeurs d'emploi des
statistiques du chômage sur quel type de
formation on s'en moque à quel prix ça
n'a pas d'importance y a-t-il des
emplois à l'arrivée ça n'est pas le
sujet non le seul but c'est de les
sortir pendant 6 mois des statistiques
du chômage pour sauver le soldat
Hollande et bien entendu les régions
sont les bienvenus bah voyons c'est non
c'est non parce que je refuse de
participer à une
mascarade c'est non parce que nous ne
croyons pas à
l'assistana et non parce que nous
refusons de trahir ceux qui nous ont
fait confiance on a un seul discours
c'est le même avant et c'est le même
après l'élection la politique ça doit
être aussi clair que
cela la droite ça n'est pas la gauche et
vous ne nous faites pas confiance pour
appliquer la même politique de l'emploi
que celle de François
Hollande nous avons commencé donc par
baisser les indemnités des élus par
parce que je crois que si les élus ne
s'appliquent pas eux-mêmes ce qu'ils
demandent aux autres nous ne serons
jamais crédibles nous avons fait Patrice
un plan d'économie parce que je refuse
d'augmenter les impôts et les taxes et
que je considère que ça suffit qu'en
France ce soit toujours les mêmes qui
payent la classe moyenne auquelle on
demande toujours plus et qui reçoit
toujours
moins nous voulons reprendre en main les
gardes et les abords de nos lycées et
nous déposerons systématiquement quand
il y aura des dégradations parce que je
veux que ce soit la semaine suivante
avec le bleu de travail et quand on a
dégradé un équipement public on le
répare la semaine d'après c'est cela
aussi le respect dans la République
française vous savez j'ai la conviction
que les Français ne doutent pas de nos
idées ils doutent de notre détermination
à les mettre en œuvre il ne votent pas
effen parce qu'il ne croi pas dans nos
discours il votent effen parce qu'il
doutent de nos actes le problème de la
droite et du centre en France ce n'est
pas trop en dire c'est de ne pas en
faire assez et c'est toi Nicolas qui a
été le premier à secouer ce dénis de ce
qu'était la politique de la droite en
France alors je veux que vous sachiez
que dans nos régions notre détermination
sera total que dans notre région
personne ne nous dictera ce que nous
avons le droit de penser et ce que nous
n'avons pas le droit de dire arrêtons de
chercher à plaire au sondages et aux
médias soyons libres
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parce que ce n'est plus un
jeu parce qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement
de la conquête du pouvoir il y a quelque
chose de beaucoup plus profond qui se
joue avons-nous bien compris que notre
pays est en train de se
défaire je refuse de voir nos flurons
industriels comme Peugeot racheter les
uns après les autres je n'accepte plus
que quelques syndicalistes qui ne
représentent que empêche des salariés de
travailler plus s'ils le souhaitent dans
leur
entreprise je ne peux pas
comprendre que celui qui travaille ne
gagne pas plus que celui qui reste chez
lui je ne veux plus que dans le même
temps où on contrôle sans cesse toujours
plus les honnêtes gens on soit incapable
de punir ceux qui ont incendié la Gard
de moirant une république forte avec les
faibles et FAI avec les
forts nous ne voulons plus Nicolas
fermer les yeux sur le fait que dans le
même temps où les traités doivent payer
toujours plus cher l'accès aux soins on
offre gratuitement notre système de
santé à des étrangers qui n'ont même
jamais cotisé par leur travail sur le
sol
national et enfin quand allons nous
ouvrir les yeux sur le fait que nous
nourrissons en notre sein des
terroristes des Français passés par
l'école de la République et qui tournent
leur haine et leurs armes contre un pays
qui les a beaucoup trop généreusement
nourris est-ce cela
est-ce cela la France est-ce cela ce que
nous voulons pour nos enfants oui il y a
un danger il y a un danger
d'indélitement culturel et politique de
la nation oui les Français sont en
colère et en ont assez de tout cela ils
savent que notre pays a une énergie
incroyable mais ils ne comprennent plus
pourquoi les politiques ont mis une
telle rage à mettre la France la tête à
l'envers et inversé systématiquement
toutes nos valeurs cela fait trop
longtemps que nous fermons les yeux cela
fait trop longtemps dans ce quinquena
que nous nous taisons cela fait trop
longtemps qu'on n la réalité les
français eux l'ont bien compris et
attendent de nous un discours qui soit
déterminé et j'accuse les socialistes
d'avoir trahi les valeurs de la
République parce qu'il y a une époque où
être socialiste c'était jores c'était
ferry c'était clé
c'était des gens qui défendaient l'école
et la nation ça n'est pas cela le PS de
Hollande le PS de Hollande c'est Madame
Valo Belkassem qui nous fait honte quand
elle écoute sans même réagir un
salafiste l'humilié en direct sur un
plateau de
télévision quand on est ministre de la
République on a le courage de dire que
l'islamisme radical n'a pas sa place en
France l'islamisme radical c'est dehors
ici c'est la République on en respecte
les règles où on part
[Applaudissements]
nous ne nous sommes pas engagé en
politique pour assister en silence au
déclin de notre
pays nous savons plus que jamais
pourquoi nous faisons de la politique
depuis que nous avons compris que la
France était mortelle comme le dit si
bien finkelcot la France est malade mais
la France n'est pas morte quand les
Français vous l'avez dit ont sorti les
drapeaux devant les fenêtres quandil dit
sinon qu'il ne voulit pas que la voix de
la France s'éteigne cette crise que
traverse notre pays peut-être salvatrice
n'oubliez jamais que dans son histoire
notre pays a toujours été capable de se
renouveler et de se redresser il l'a
fait à bouvine quand tout semblait perdu
il l'a fait à valmi quand la jeune
République s'est sauvée il l'a fait avec
Bonapart quand il a redonné à la France
sa fierté il l'a fait en 1871 après
l'humiliante défaite face à l'Allemagne
il l'a fait le 18 juin 40 et en 1958 de
fois avec le général de Gaulle c'était
une période de géant politique qui
n'avait pas peur de renverser les
tables alors oui Nicolas et tu le portes
avec détermination les élus doivent
reprendre le pouvoir nous en avons assez
d'être gouverné par des techniciens au
petitpied ce ne sont pas les
fonctionnaires qui décident ce sont les
politiques qui doivent commander et
quand on n pas capable de prendre le
gouvernail on va faire autre
chose
alors pour cela il y a une seule
question une seule question qui vaille
et ça n'est pas le concours des
caractères des uns et des autres de la
primaire qui nous intéresse au fond la
seule question qui vaille c'est celle du
Cap c'est celle des valeurs nous sommes
face à un choix essentiel que veut la
droite à quoi
sert-elle certains fins stratèges
politiques pensent qu'il faut que la
droite le moins possible qu'elle fasse
des clins d'œils à la gauche en pensant
déjà au second tour de la présidentielle
dire à chacun ce qu'il a envie
d'entendre ne rien penser et surtout en
faire encore moins une droite qui est
une pâ copie de la gauche les déficits
en moins Luc et encore ce cheminlà
n'amènera que de nouvelles trahisons il
peut permettre de gagner la
présidentielle il peut permettre de
caracoler dans les sondages mais c'est
un chemin d'indignité dans lequel on
trahira une fois de plus nos valeurs et
à l'arrivée nous n'aurons pas redresser
notre
pays le temps le temps mes amis de l'eau
tiède et des mou en politique et révolu
vous avez le droit à des politiques qui
ont une colonne vertébrale qui ont de
vraies convictions qui ne changent pas
d'idée à chaque rentrée politique oui
nous sommes de droite nous sommes fiers
nous n'avons pas l'intention de nous
excuser de nos valeurs nous voulons une
droite de valeur une droite qui assume
ses idées au grand jour sereinement mais
avec une détermination
totale nous croyons au travail et bien
nous combattons la cistana nous exigeons
qu'en contrepartie du RSA il y ait
systématiquement des heures de travail
le seul vrai social c'est le social par
le travail cela fait longtemps que je le
réclame nos amis alsaciens ont
totalement raison le gouvernement veut
les faire taire N nous devons prendre
l'engagement que nous rétablirons les
contreparties systématiques pour le RSA
il y a des droits il y a des
devoirs nous croyons dans les classes
moyennes et bien il faudra rétablir les
allocations familiales pour tous parce
que la famille a été massacrée par les
socialistes nous croyons dans la famille
et bien je n'ai pas changé d'avis sur la
loi tobira je refuse de garder cette loi
je refuse d'AC que dans notre pays on
détruise l'affiliation comme tu l'as
très bien dit hier l'avenir de la France
ça n'est pas d'acheter le ventre d'une
femme pour qu'elle fasse un enfant et
qu'on le donne ensuite à quelqu'un
d'autre à sa
[Applaudissements]
naissance nous croyons dans la justice
et bien il faut mettre à égalité les
retraites du public et du privé et
supprimer tous les régimes spéciaux de
retraite à commencé par les nôtres parce
que sinon nous ne supprimerons jamais
ceux de la CG
nous croyons à la
laïcité et bien arrêtons tous les petits
accommodements avec le communautarisme
pas d'horaire différenciés dans les
services publics pas de port du voile
dans les services publics de la France
pas de compromis avec les intégrist de
l'islam notre pays mes
amis ne vient pas de nulle part il a une
histoire il porte une civilisation et
personne personne ne nous fera jamais
dire que notre pays doit renoncer à
lui-même pour accueillir ceux qui
viennent d'ailleurs c'est une absurdité
que de demander de retirer les crèches
de nos lieux publics la France est tout
à la fois la Révolution française et les
racines chrétiennes et ce n'est pas en
niant notre identité que l'on intégrera
les
autres pourquoi en sommes-nous arrivz là
et je voudrais finir par là il y a une
époque où les étrangers s'intégrait
parce qu'il venaient en France pour
travailler et en disant à leurs enfants
mon fils ma fille tu dois devenir plus
français que les Français et bien des
personnes ici sont les incarnations et
les visages de ces parcours qui étaient
ceux d'une France qui reposait sur
l'assimilation complète de ceux qui
venaient parce qu'il venaient en
admirant nos valeurs et notre culture
c'était ça la France et ça marchait
aujourd'hui on en F plus on nen finit
plus de s'excuser de notre histoire on
ne transmet plus de fierté on semble
avoir honte de ce que nous sommes nous
pratiquons l'autodénigrement Macron nous
explique que la France est raciste Vals
nous explique que si nous avons des
terroristes c'est parce qu'il y a des
ghettos et qu'il faudrait mettre sans
cesse plus d'argent dans les quartiers
dans le même temps nous abandonnons la
France rurale honte à vous on en finit
pas diriger la différence en valeur
cardinale alors qu'il faut d'abord
enseigner à nos enfants ce que nous
avons commun une appartenance commune
une certaine manière de vivre de penser
d'agir c'est cela la France et l'école
l'école doit être un lieu de qui est
aujourd'hui un lieu de déconstruction
doit redevenir un lieu de transmission
de notre culture et de nos valeurs alors
évidemment Christian et merci à toi de
l'avoir défendu il faut retirer la
nationalité à ceux qui ont trahi la
confiance de la République
évidemment alors évidemment aussi
Christian il faut que nous empêchions
tous ceux qui partent hors de France
pour aller au djihad de revenir et de
remettre un pied en France parce que
quand on part au dihad c'est un aller
sans
retour et
surtout
surtout il faut avoir le courage de dire
que la question ça n'est pas seulement
la déchéance de nationalité mais c'est
aussi l'acquisition de la nationalité
parce que la France ne beaucoup trop
généreusement la nationalité française à
des gens qui ne parlent pas notre langue
qui ne respectent pas notre culture et
qui ne travaillent même pas pour faire
vivre leur famille il faut moins de
naturalisation la France ne peut plus le
supporter au fond vous ne nous demandez
qu'une chose soyez la droite soyez une
droite de valeur ne nous trahissez pas
alors oui nous en sommes convaincus la
flamme de notre pays n'est pas éteinte
il suffit de souffler sur les bresses
pour que cette énergie se rallume nous
voulons retrouver l'amour de la France
l'amour de la France ce n'est pas un
gros mot porte sa fierté en nous
réapprendre à aimer la France comme le
disait la philosophe Simon veale il faut
que la France soit de retour oui il faut
que la France soit de retour notre pays
n'a pas à renoncer à ce qu'il est il
doit redevenir ce qu'il était un pays
qui reposait sur le travail sur la
méritocratie sur le respect un pays fier
de son
identité la France de retour c'est un
pays qui transmet à nouveau ses valeurs
la France de retour c'est un pays qui ne
change pas de nature la France de retour
ce n'est pas à la République de
s'adapter aux étrangers c'est aux
étrangers de s'adapter à la République
il est temps de retrouver l'espoir la
seule mission qui bagne c'est celle-ci
que la France soit de retour merci à
[Applaudissements]
tous